mais mais oui oui ça fait trente mille
francs que j'avais mais mais oui ce sont
les trente mille fois que j'avais mais
nous sommes et comment je vais faire
tu te rends compte je les ai perdus
j'espère tu
mais c'est pas à moi sargeant fait pas
d'avoir c'est à mon patron je devais ne
la portait tout à l'heure quand je t'ai
vu tu sais c'est perdu vaincu mais comme
c'est pas possible je te colle gérante
vous fait pas de mauvais sang va perdre
d'argent n'est pas mortelle quand mille
francs de perdu dix de retrouvés
mam jeudi si c'était un mois encore demi
mal des commandes me mall mâles entiers
oui je te pourquoi j'aurais perdu trente
mille francs moindre coût comme ça ne
sera pas non s'offrant par son proche
dit pas à la rigueur c'est comme si
c'était des petits traite
essentiellement françaises avaient l'âme
et oui sortez le tiers provisionnel à
cela je vais pas perdu ma seconde année
en raison de gira les bons sens vont
avec les mungiki veste bellaoui sont les
voilà il était sérieusement désire
trouver des sites les enfants vous
trouvez que j'aurais perdu ni quand je
réfléchisse à une perdue quand j'aurai
fait comment j'aurais fait il aurait
fallu que j'emprunte à un sauveur bah
ils m'auraient pas prêter sauveur il
m'avait pas prêter il n'aurait pas
prêter ce pourri et après tout le bien
que j'ai fait j'ai mangé chez lui
pendant un an et tout à prouver
mais sa période qu'est ce qu'il regrette
d'avoir demandé qu'est ce que je
regrette ils apposent sauver sauveur
avec moi sans faille mais alors qui
j'aurais demandé alors je vais demander
à un patient alors elle m'aurait pas
prêter bastien il aurait su que sauveur
rim a refusé mon régiment se pourim
aurait refusé à moitié après tout le
bien que j ai fais tu sais pas quand je
mangeais pas chez sauveur je manger chez
lui les mains s'affairent 1 mais je leur
dirai je leur dirai je leur dirais vous
et toi et un sauveur de pourri ensemble
qui s'assemblent pactole mais allez donc
même sac à l'aller c'est pas la peine je
sais vous ce soir mes dents mais
maintenant je sais wissant c'est bien
simple jean n'est pas bon non droit qui
j'aurais demandé à qui j'aurais demandé
j'aurais demandé à un horaire je connais
à peine et beaucoup de courage et moi
peut-être qu'ils me les aurait prêté
nombre des tués il me connaît pas alors
il les aurait prêté tu te rends compte
des normes vertes quoi n'est pas une
vraie prête et c'est tout pourri de
sauveur et bassem votre vtt et mais
qu'elle s'était battue temps mais
réussit une passe et au miel ce type là
il faut le garder lui faut regarder je
leur jeu leur direz vous n'avez pas
honte
un étrange il me prêtez vous ne prêtez
pas vous êtes mes frères vous soit
disant l'amitié les frères à laquelle
elle est allée à la grève demain olala
mais quel principe ce north bay axim pas
s'il faut le garder lui
heureusement camembert on a mais si ça
se trouve même pas il aurait voulu plus
du rand
comme je le connais il m'aurait dit non
non c'est pas la peine c'est pas la
peine pour toi de moi mais tient bon ben
voilà c'est ton argent juste les rangs
c'est normal enfin mais notre ami
français pas la peine
alors parce qu'il se serait vexé on
aurait pu il aurait en justice des
procès et des rela bon ça va ça va jaur
écrasé le coup ça va mais quel brave
type jeunes or berne et tu te rends
compte qu elle brave type jeu ils me
prêtent 30 mille francs
il veut pas que je lui rende et bien
puisque c'est comme ça tout de suite je
vais aller lui demander ses trente mille
francs à norbert et on en parlera plus
voilà